well guys the League of Legends World
Championship grand finals might have
been boring as hell but the offseason
isn't Griffin the Korean League of
Legends team that's been embroiled in
scandal for the last two months he's
back at it
investigations resignation secret
recordings there's a lot to talk about
well guys world's is over and before the
dust has even settled there were more
bombshells in rip and scandal for those
who haven't kept up on your Korean
League drama or seen our previous video
on the topic here's a tldr first we have
Griffon Miss Korean League of Legends
team that's a bit of a Cinderella story
they debuted a few years ago made it to
the lck and have come first or second in
the regular season and playoffs every
split since flash forward to a few
months ago just a week before the League
of Legends World Championship group
stage begins and they fire their coach a
guy named CV max now this is pretty
weird because CV max has been with the
team since the beginning and he is
credited with being a big part of the
team's success a couple of the Gryphon
players do interviews when they kind of
call CD max out he sees them on stream
and [ __ ] just goes off he says that the
Griffon director a guy by the name of
Cho Vietnam was allegedly a kind of
tyrant who fired CB max of spite and
jealousy Cho apparently denied that see
V Max had any part in the team success
he wouldn't let him stream during his
time with the team and nepotism
according to CB max ran rampant under
Cho apparently this was particularly the
case when it came to a Griffin player by
the name of sword who that's about as
close to as a tldr as I'm ever gonna get
next thing you know Espo's investigating
riot korea's poking their nose in it and
two korean senators are making
statements on its basically become
bigger than league of legends and hey
there's a lot more to the original story
so if you do want to get caught up you
should click slightly above my head and
to the right for our previous video on
the subject okay so now that we're
caught up what's new well since that
time a Wyatt has completed an interim
investigation into everything that
happened and Cho you know that guy's TV
max Lang all those allegations at yeah
he's gone violation earlier this week on
November 12th the parent company of
Griffin released a statement on the
whole scandal and according to her
aizen's Kevin Kim director cho took
responsibility
the CEO of Griffin also apologizes for
everything that's happened and promises
to cooperate with riots ongoing
investigation just a reminder about Cho
this is the guy at the heart of pretty
much all of CD Max and Kenobi's
allegations towards Griffin he was
accused of frankly terrible behavior of
manipulation of nepotism of
mismanagement and now he's gone
one hopes that the unfortunate
potentially illegal situations that this
guy allegedly created when he was on
Griffin leave with him although somehow
I don't think this is gonna end anytime
soon as for Cho himself well he gave a
two-part blockbuster tell-all interview
to a Korean media outlet cult sports
Chosun in these interviews he apparently
gives a very different account of what
happened and according to former Los
Angeles valiant translator Andrew Kim
throws some pretty crazy curveballs at
CV max in particular now one more point
about the Griffin's statement there was
a note in there that some people
translated or interpreted as meaning
that Griffin was going to blow up their
whole roster and rebuild and that would
be pretty [ __ ] spicy given how well
Griffin's roster has performed over the
years and at Worlds in particular but it
may not be true according to former
league of legends Pro and coach Lobo
dokgo appearing on Travis gafford's
hotline league this may have been a
misinterpretation or a mistranslation
and Griffin were actually talking about
rebuilding the eternal culture not the
actual roster oh that's not gonna be a
thing by the way I think a Griffin does
get to keep their officer when they when
they said we like bill from beginning
they mean like we build their culture
not we build their from what I know it's
rebuild their roster not are not rebuild
that rebuild their roster rebuild their
culture not their roster they get rides
over flirt
but what about that riot Korea
investigation into the alleged player
tampering with Kennedy
well according to their interim report
apparently when it comes to all the
major allegations everything's all good
okay [ __ ] I'm not gonna get into the
dirty nitty-gritty details here but
essentially there are different rules
for players on loan and foreign imports
when it comes to the lck and LPL the
korean and chinese league of legends'
completes those rules were thought to be
in conflict at various points but riots
investigation determined that there was
no player tampering and that no one
violated the rules for players on loan
when it came to Konami in the LPL we
really also stated that at this time
there is not enough evidence to
determine whether Konami was coerced or
threatened or blackmailed in any way now
the ruling did admit that some of the
rules in place could be exploited and
that they're going to be making changes
to them in time for 2020 and remember
guys this is an interim investigation so
there will be more to come so I have
this guy on Twitter and every time I
make a tweet he replies with something
about my mustache and how much he loves
it look I appreciate it I like the fact
that I got brand value from this thing
I'm getting a little worried I don't
want to wake up one day and have this
guy shaving off my mustache and putting
into a [ __ ] ziploc bag okay so fence
he's might kill me now you may actually
that may actually be the trigger that
causes him to kill me
I love you haiku you're all right man